Narrator:
THE GREEN'S CREEK MINE
IS THE LARGEST SILVER MINE
IN THE LAST FRONTIER,
PRODUCING MORE
THAN 8 MILLION OUNCES
OF SILVER IN 2015.
BUT TURNING THESE ROCKS
INTO RICHES IS RISKY WORK.
MINERS AT GREEN'S CREEK
HAVE TO CHIP AWAY
AT THE MOUNTAIN'S FOUNDATION
12 FEET AT A TIME,
USING HUNDREDS
OF POUNDS OF EXPLOSIVES.
BUT GENERATING A BLAST
ISN'T AS SIMPLE
AS LIGHTING A STICK OF DYNAMITE.
THEY HAVE TO SET
LIQUID EXPLOSIVES SEVERAL FEET
INTO THE ROCK
IN A PERFECT ARCH PATTERN.
THE NATURAL ARCH IS INHERENTLY
A SAFER GEOMETRIC FORM.
SO IN THE PRIMARY DEVELOPMENTS
IN THE ORE ACCESSES,
WE WANT AN ARCH.
Narrator: PLACING THE EXPLOSIVE
REQUIRES PRECISION
AND ONE OF THE MINE'S
MIGHTIEST MACHINES --
THE TWO BOOM JUMBO DRILL.
Man: DOUBLE BOOM JUMBO
IS LIKE A TRANSFORMER.
♪♪
Narrator: THIS 23-TON MACHINE
CAN BORE 12 FEET
INTO THE TOUGHEST ROCK,
USING NOT ONE,
BUT TWO HYDRAULIC ARMS.
FORTY-FIVE HOLES LATER,
THE CREW HAS SET
THE EXPLOSION PATTERN.
THEY'VE PLACED EACH HOLE
SPECIFICALLY
TO CREATE A CHAIN REACTION.
SO, THIS
IS OUR FIRST HOLE,
WHICH IS GONNA MAKE A HOLE
FROM THIS BIG TO THAT BIG.
AND WE'RE
JUST MAKING A LITTLE HOLE
INTO A BIGGER HOLE
ALL THE WAY AROUND
TILL WE GET THIS BIG HOLE
THAT WE'RE STANDING IN.
NOW THEY'RE READY
FOR THE POWDERMAN.
THE POWDERMAN
PUMPS LIQUID EXPLOSIVE
INTO EACH OF THE 45 HOLES
DRILLED INTO THE ROCK.
HE USES A DANGEROUS MIXTURE
OF FERTILIZER AND DIESEL.
Satre:
IT'S ALL LINKED TO A CENTRALIZED
BLASTING SYSTEM.
IT'S VERY SENSITIVE.
AND WE CERTAINLY DON'T WANT
ANY EXTERNAL INTERFERENCE.
AND WE DON'T WANNA PUT
ANYBODY AT RISK
FOR HAVING EXPLOSIVES
GO OFF PREMATURELY.
Narrator:
THE TEAM HAS SET THE EXPLOSIVES
AND EVACUATED THE TUNNEL.
IT'S THE MOMENT OF TRUTH
FOR THE MINERS.
LET'S GO AHEAD
AND CONFIRM.
Narrator: AND WITH THE CLICK
OF A BUTTON...
...A POWERFUL EXPLOSION
BLASTS THE ORE.
ALL RIGHT, BOYS.
GOOD JOB.
OKAY.
THE BLAST WAS SUCCESSFUL.
THE EXPLOSIVES
BROKE FREE 300 TONS OF ROCK.
IT'S A POTENTIALLY
PROSPEROUS HAUL.